let's go to our friend bitdefender from
cancun mexico this is not eric from
cancun this is a different cancun caller
who goes by bitdefender bit you're on
hello david hello
i hope you're welcome um
i wanted to talk about something that
happened in mexico that i think
some americans ought to know
just in case something similar happens
in the states okay so
the 10th of april we had a special
election of sorts uh alexander
mandato which is
essentially an election where you go to
vote
to
get rid of the president is it almost
like it's almost like a no-confidence
vote of the of the people right
exactly now it sounds
sort of democratic but the reality of it
is that it's something that mostly
exists in
autocratic countries
and countries that
well leaders that want to campaign
constantly you know what i mean yes
especially in countries that pretend or
have democratic democratic systems that
you know have electoral law of sorts
but you you very well know that the
elections are not fair and free sure you
know
uh venezuela ecuador um
some other latin american countries have
this form i know mexico has it
given the rise of these forms of
you know governments and uh governors
do you think uh
we will see something similar in the
states i don't think so i think it would
be
how presidential elections run
at least in theory
is so set in stone
that i don't believe that there's going
to be the putting in the the in
statement of such a mechanism and also
you know as you point out one of the
ideas of it the propaganda value of it
is that you can kind of constantly be
running an election and that can
sometimes help to coalesce and organize
people
the republican party has already figured
out how to do the same thing by by
saying democrats are going to try to
steal it which is what they did in 2020
and so they already kind of have a
mechanism to make that rallying cry so
no i don't expect that to be uh
instated in the united states
also now that you mention it
when you know given the nature of
electoral law in your in the states um
what what gives you so much confidence
that the you know electoral law is so
set in stone
you know me coming from a country where
we have a an actual
federal institute dedicated to electoral
management and the states
don't really have one you know
uh i mean i don't maybe i'm naive to
think that but the the only real sense i
have is that if anything was going to
structurally change the way elections
are done it would be something like the
national popular vote interstate compact
where states can decide
we'll we'll just give our electors to
the winner of the popular vote but
beyond that there's not really any
serious initiatives there i mean they're
they're trying to steal it by not
officially changing the big picture but
by doing voter suppression at the state
level uh strategic voter id closing
polling places that they're looking to
do it piecemeal rather than any with any
big mechanism like a public
no-confidence vote or that type of it's
just what they're doing so i'm basing it
on what i see
absolutely well that's about it thank
you dude all right thank you there's a
bit defender from cancun
my audience knows i read i read a ton of
books i read nonfiction i read fiction
at night i'm always trying to consume
information and the truth is i don't
have the time to read every non-fiction
book that i would like to read
one thing i do not have time to add to
what i'm reading in paper form is more
history but i want to know about history
and that's where our sponsor blinkist
comes in blinkist doesn't replace
reading books cover to cover the way i
love to do but for example with
everything going on right now with roe v
wade i wanted more of a detailed history
of roe v wade in the united states so on
blinkist i was able to get a 15-minute
condensed audiobook of the mary ziegler
book abortion and the law in america roe
v wade to the present and in 15 minutes
i get a great overview blinkist also has
slide presentations that will take you
about 15 minutes to go through so it's
not to replace reading it's in addition
to for me you get the key takeaways from
blinkist from the books i would
certainly otherwise miss out on you can
try blinkist for free for seven days and
get a 25 discount off of a subscription
at blinkist.com pacman the link is down
below